President Biden is in Lithuania this
morning for crucial meetings with
America's allies in NATO the leaders
there have got a lot to talk about but
the main focus will be almost entirely
on Russia and the threat it poses to
Eastern Europe Nancy Cordes has made her
way to The Summit in Vilnius that's the
capital of Lithuania and she joins us
now Nancy good morning
good morning to you Tony and the leaders
who are gathered here are starting out
this Summit with a win an agreement to
allow a powerful Nordic country to join
the NATO alliance a signal to Putin they
argue that his unprovoked war against
Ukraine has United the West against him
[Music]
and Biden arrived in lithuania's capital
to Good News NATO member turkey suddenly
dropping its opposition to Sweden's NATO
membership Sweden will now follow
Finland into the growing Alliance this
is historic moment
adding a Finland swing to uh to Nato is
consequential
this is the first meeting of NATO
leaders since the Wagner mercenary group
attempted Mutiny in Russia last month
a Russian spokesman confirmed that
Russian President Vladimir Putin met
with Wagner leader yevgeni pragosian
five days after that uprising
has not been seen since
protecting NATO's Eastern flank from an
increasingly unstable Russia is at the
top of the agenda today you're going to
defend every instrument
and as Russia's assault on Ukraine
enters its 17th month leaders here say
they'll unveil a long-awaited reform
path today that Ukraine can take to
someday join NATO itself how long do you
anticipate it will take Ukraine to make
those reforms once the war has ended I
can't put a timetable on it I don't
believe that you will see that coming
out of here this is about
the substance of democratic and security
sector reforms and getting those right
but that approach appears to be too
vague for Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski who is on his way here right
now and just issued a scathing statement
saying that it's quote unprecedented and
absurd to place new requirements on
Ukraine without a specific timetable for
NATO membership he says it's only going
to embolden Russia and that he's
prepared to make that case when he gets
here later today Gail
Nancy we thank you